♪♪♪♪
-Hey, everybody, welcome bac
to our digital-only series
called "Corrections."
I want to stress, again,
this is not on television.
It looks like it's
on television, but it is not
I say that because one of th
comments, the last time
we did this, was,
"How the [bleep] is this on TV?"
[ Laughter ]
Which is a question
that is both rude
and fair.
[ Laughter ]
So, again,
this is digital-only.
We made a mistake earlier
in tonight's "Closer Look.
It was pointed out to me.
I said, "journey man,"
instead of "journeyman."
-Right.
Like "fireman."
Right, journeyman.
A Journey man
would be like Steve Perry.
[ Laughter ]
Someone said
I used "embattled" wrong.
I used "embattled" to mean
you know, somebody
in controversy
and it was pointed out to me
that it means
someone who is actually read
to fight is embattled.
So I looked it up
on the old Merriam-Webster
and, indeed,
the first definition
is "ready to fight,"
and the second was
the way I used it,
"engaged in controversy."
So that person really --
They [bleep] up.
[ Laughter ]
Because sometimes words,
you know,
mean more than one thing
and, if you want to live
in a word -- world.
[ Laughter ]
If you want to live in a world
without homonyms,
that's fine.
For you!
[ Laughter ]
Probably walking around,
being like,
"That's a pitcher of water
and that's a...
baseball thrower man."
[ Cluck ]
[ Laughter ]
So, "embattled"
means two things.
Pogs.
We mentioned Pogs last night
And someone --
This isn't really a correction
but they pointed out, they said,
"I don't think you wrote tha
because I know how old you are
and I know when Pogs came ou
and I don't think you were
a 31-year-old Pog enthusiast."
[ Laughter ]
And it's true --
I did not write that joke.
And then, I did the math
and I'm happy to report
that John Mulaney was
a 22-year-old Pog enthusiast
[ Laughter ]
A lot of our corrections
are based on things
I corrected
in other corrections,
so that's one of the core
problems of this whole endeavor.
[ Laughter ]
I said, "The prime ministe
of Ireland."
Someone said it's actually
not the prime minister,
and then they gave me an Irish
word and then I said it.
And I said,
"It's not prime minister."
I said, "Tay-sha," [Taoiseach]
and then,
a bunch of people said,
it's not pronounced "Tay-sha,"
it's pronounced "Tea-sock,
which I'm sure is close,
but, probably
still a little wrong.
And the reason I came up
with "Tay-sha" is,
on YouTube, sometimes,
you can go and type in like,
"How to pronounce" --
and I spelled it --
and then they do a thing
where like a swirl comes i
as the word's on the screen.
And it went like this,
it went, "Tay-sha."
So, I just wouldn't trust
those things.
[ Laughter ]
Also, it bums me out because w
do, like all late night shows,
we have an old Irish poet
on staff...
[ Laughter ]
...who's supposed to look ou
for stuff like this,
but Old Seamus, well...
[ Laughter ]
...he was in his cups,
so to speak.
[ Laughter ]
And I even went to him.
I'm like, "How do you say this?"
And he was like --
[ Irish accent ] oi, just like
going on about verdant fields.
[ Laughter ]
And, once he gets up going
about those...
[ Laughter ]
And he's like --
[ Irish accent ]
I'll tell you for a wee taste.
And I'm like, "Not now."
[ Laughter ]
Always wants a wee taste.
What else we got?
Oh, so this one's
really had a long tail,
insofar as corrections
on corrections.
Ben Franklin's wife,
her name was Deborah
and I pointed out that seeme
very anachronistic to me,
Deborah, in Colonial times
Then, a bunch of people
pointed out
Deborah is actually
in the Bible
and so then I said,
"That's crazy.
That would be like
if Candace was in the Bible.
Candace is in the Bible.
[ Laughter ]
Candace is the queen
of Ethiopia,
so how about that?
Then, somebody else was like
"Bigger problem, bud.
Ben Franklin and Deborah
weren't married."
-[ Laughs ]
-Mm.
-This is a true story.
Based on what I read
on Wikipedia.
[ Laughter ]
Deborah marries
another fella, okay?
She met Ben Franklin.
He proposed.
Deborah's mom said
it was a no-go.
She marries some other fella
who then is a bad guy,
steals her dowry,
goes to the West Indies.
This is all true,
according to Wikipedia.
Goes to the West Indies
and they don't know
what happened to him.
Some people say he died,
but she couldn't
legally marry Ben Franklin
because of bigamy laws,
so they were common-law marrie
their whole life
because of that.
And his name was even more -
her first husband.
His name was even
more anachronistic
than Candace or Deborah.
Luke Skywalker.
[ Laughter ]
We've been talking a bit
about "Lord of the Rings"
and I've given a bit of stick.
But I want to stress,
just because I didn't love
those books
does not mean I begrudge
anyone the right --
I want all people to love
the books that make them happy
But I did --
I did mention one of the books
and I said it was
"Return to the King"
and it is "Return of the King.
And I think, in my head,
I said "Return to the King
because I was thinking
about how fast
I returned it to the library
[ Laughter ]
So, I think a pretty good week
And, again,
this is sort of an experimen
that we're trying here,
which, I believe the best wa
to engage with the Interne
is to read and respond
to everything.
[ Laughter ]
Just on a mental health level.
But I want you to know --
you can criticize me,
but I am
ready for those criticisms
I am both embattled
and embattled.
[ Laughter ]
And, now, I'm just going
to stare at the camera
until Amber says,
"That's enough."
-That's enough.
[ Laughter ]
That's enough, Seth!